I'll keep talking about the enormous
scope of cyber security and all the
lucrative job offers inside that but
I'll keep getting this one question and
it's quite obvious why will you do a job
apart from all the other reasons there
is one reason that stands first and that
is money and there is a lot of money in
cyber security honestly I'm not
exaggerating but many people won't
believe me because they will expect
blacks of packages as a fresher
everything takes time and if you are
consistent if you have the right skill
set no one is stopping you from earning
millions or even lacks per month so gear
up for this video as I will be sharing
the top 5 most popular job profiles in
cyber security and what are their
packages and salaries in India as well
as abroad for freshers as well as
experienced so let's get started first
of all this list is not in any order
these are the top five profiles that are
trending right now and will only boom in
the future and also the figures I will
tell you will be your fixed base pay the
concept of CTC involves a lot of
stockholdings other benefits in the
number so I'll be telling you just what
you will get in your monthly paycheck
excluding taxes number one penetration
testers these people are also called by
the name of security analyst security
Engineers based on the job profile and
Company but to give you a clear idea
these people proactively identify
threats and issues in an organization's
critical infrastructure both in their
software and Hardware products to let
the owner know and fix the issues
appropriately and they are immensely
important to any ID dependent business
and companies are slowly realizing their
worth and increasing their pay but
getting hard as a fresher here it's a
bit tricky because this is a skill heavy
job to talk about salaries in India as a
fresher you can get six to seven LPA in
the starting this will also include your
training budget and other benefits you
can do any certification from a popular
vendor such as offensive security EC
Council or Sans and also you get chance
to visit and attend offline conferences
namely nelcon besides orasp even Defcon
and black hat if you get some experience
of two three years your salary can jump
to 12 to 15 LPA but if you keep working
for five or more years your salary may
even go up to 25 to 30 LPA if I talk
about foreign countries when you get
paid in dollars your salary can be 100K
dollars per year when you start and if
you keep working for five plus years of
experience your salary can go to 160 to
180k per year if you want to crack ceh
and what if I tell you that you can do
that with a training that can even make
you land a job in cyber security then
you should try simply learn cyber
Security Experts master program this is
the program that will teach you all the
fundamentals and also the advanced
skills that will make you crack industry
stock certifications such as ceh
cissp cism ccsp and SEC plus the biggest
advantage of this course is that you
will get ceh exam voucher included in
this course so at the end of this course
you can be a certified ethical hacker so
you will learn the complete official
syllabus of ceh version 12. and not only
that you will also get the training for
cissp that is the flagship and gold
standard certificate in infosec that
will involve all the aspects of infosec
such as management design architecture
and controls and not only that you will
also get trainings for certified Cloud
professional CompTIA Network plus and
cism as electives and this course is
very helpful that's not me telling you
can read the reviews on the page of how
immensely this course has benefited the
people around so if you want to enroll
the application is really very simple go
to the description there is a link click
on the link go to the course page review
all the details click on enroll now when
you get to the checkout page enter my
coupon code
ytba15 to get a special discount because
you are watching me and then fill in all
the details required from you and just
enroll in this Best in Class training
from Top experts number two security
analyst these are the blue teamers they
are also called by the name sock analyst
cyber security analyst forensic analyst
and these people are constantly watching
out for Real Time threats so that they
can alert and prevent them from causing
any harm and they are the first line of
defense of any infosec department and
this is the reason why they are required
in any info Department even when they
don't have proactive pen testers they
will definitely have blue teamers
because they are the first one to be
hired they are defensive in nature if I
talk about salaries in India as a
fresher you can get 5 to 7 LPA for two
to three hours of experience you can get
10 to 15 LPA and for five plus years of
experience you can go up to 20 to 25 LPA
in U.S these people are paid slightly
less than the pen testers they can start
from 100K per year and they can go up to
150 to 170k in five plus years of
experience number three cyber security
manager they are in very high demand
right now because organizations are
investing huge money in security
infrastructure because everyone knows
how important is data today just like
software development teams have project
managers we have security managers so
they decide the plan of action for IT
issues and data breaches and they create
policies for secure functioning of I.T
assets and they also onboard and manage
security projects and delegate them to
the team members rightfully and help
maintain the overall security posture
and of course you cannot be had as a
manager right away you need to have at
least five years of experience in a
security domain and then you can be
starting as a manager for starting of
course the salaries are very high in
India these people start from 15 to 20
LPA and they can even go to 30 to 40 LP
if they keep working for four to five
years and some people will even touch 50
LPA in us they start from 110 to 120k
per year for more experience of about 5
years they can go to 200k as well number
four security auditor it often gets
overlooked by beginners because it
doesn't appeal to them and doesn't
Fascinate them but it is a very
responsible job and importantly
undoubtedly it's very important in
infosec Department we often need to
comply to certain government regulatory
policies when we deal with customer data
or public data such as Bank information
and financial information pii or health
information so we need to comply and
follow certain standards so all the
infrastructure is regularly audited by
these teams for compliance and they are
also responsible for identification of
risk and issues they are also called
Risk Managers IIT Auditors or GRC so
they ultimately are responsible for
managing risk and compliance and of
course here as well you cannot join as a
fresher you need a responsible
experience but in India when you start
you can get 10 to 15 LPA and then the
growth is even better so after three to
four years even you can go up to 25 to
30 LPA in us the median is 120 to 130k
and if you work for three to four years
you can even go up to 180k number five
ciso Chief Information Security Officer
he is the backbone of the whole infosec
department you are in charge of the
infosec you are responsible for managing
everything and governing everything to
protect the IIT infrastructure keeping
it in compliance and you manage all the
security teams under you so from
auditing to budgeting to developing
infosec policies to procurement
everything it's a complete leadership
role it's an ultimate job where you will
need to have at least 10 to 15 years of
experience in security and also need to
work as a manager for five plus years in
managing a security team the salaries
are immense of course if you land it in
India when they start they can easily
get up to 30 to 40 LPA and they can even
go to uh 70 to 80 LPA if in some good
companies and also five plus years and
it's a top product based companies in
India they can even touch 100 LPA that
is one crore and in U.S it's even higher
it starts from 300 to 350k and I'm not
kidding but some offers may even go up
to 1 million USD per year when you get
experience for up to five years so these
are the top five cyber security profiles
you can apply now and enjoy great
packages and benefits but again I'm not
raising you to Cloud Nine these packages
are really very subjective they will
depend on a lot of factors including
company its size and location I'm taking
top mncs at the reference number two
your education level number three job
roles and objectives number four Market
Condition it's not good right now of
course inflation and all number five
your performance so make sure you do
your research before applying and then
you're good to go in your career so I
hope this video gave you a right idea
about the benefits of a cyber security
career and what domains to choose and
how to proceed so all the best for your
career if you're planning for it and
I'll see you in the next video but I'll
talk about another cyber security
landscape so keep watching keep learning
and goodbye